Game of Thrones night king is a
terrifying villain but he may have a
connection to one of westeros 'iz most
noble families House Stark in both the
books and TV series there are plenty of
hints indicating that the night king
could actually be a stark to understand
the connection between House Stark and
the leader of the others it's important
to understand the beginnings of each
according to the world of Ice and Fire
the long night was a winter that lasted
for an entire generation thousands of
years before the story we know takes
place during the long night the others
terrorized the first men the humans who
had settled in Westeros after much
fighting with the others one of the
first men reached an agreement with the
magical beings called the children of
the forest and joined forces with them
to repel the others who are you the fuss
man called us the children but we were
born long before them no one knows for
certain who that person was but it's
hinted that this legendary hero was bran
the Builder the first Stark who helped
establish the Nights Watch bran would go
on to work with the children to build
the magically protected wall to help
defend against the others though this
battle and the walls construction was
the first interaction between the Starks
and the others it was far from the last
before we go any further there's an
important distinction to be made between
two key figures the night King and the
night's king the night king is the
leader of the White Walkers in the game
of thrones TV series the night's king
however is someone briefly touched upon
in the Song of Ice and Fire books the
night's king was a human and the
thirteenth Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch to give you an idea of how long
ago this was Jon Snow is the 998 Lord
Commander or was briefly while serving
as commander the night's king fell in
love with a mysterious woman and
together they began making human
sacrifices to the others after 13 years
with the help of House Stark the night's
king and his otherworldly wife were both
defeated the similar names have led some
to speculate that the two may be the
same person but when asked about the
possibility george RR martin asserted
otherwise writing as for the night's
king in the books he is a legendary
figure akin to land the clever and
Brandon the Builder and no more likely
to have survived to the
day than they have so that's that
they're two different people but they
also may be deeply connected by a lot
more than just their similar names so
who is the mysterious woman who won the
heart of the old night's king turning
him to the other side it said that the
thirteenth Lord Commander saw this woman
from atop the wall in a storm of sorts
she said to have skin as white as the
moon and eyes like blue stars with skin
as cold as ice the description heavily
implies that she was one of the others
sharing their frigid pale skin and
glowing blue eyes when brand tells the
story of the night's king in a storm of
sorts he indicates that the man gave
more than just his love to the woman he
gave his soul as well
the official histories of the seven
kingdoms as represented in the world of
Ice and Fire speculate that the night's
king came from one of the northern
families of which there are many but
when old nan tells the story to bran as
bran recalls in a storm of sorts she
puts all other possibilities to rest
saying without a doubt he was a stark
the brother of the man who brought him
down the idea that the night's came from
long ago was a stark suggests that the
modern-day night king might have a
similar origin story possibly being a
stark himself when he was still a normal
men one of the most heinous taboos in
Westeros is slaying one's own kin only
in the most extreme of circumstances
which is such an act be considered
justifiable Brandon the breaker had no
problem killing his brother the night's
king but what if the night's king and
his mysterious lover had a child as old
nan confirms to bran in the novel's it's
entirely possible with human white
Walker couplings resulting in what she
calls quote terrible half-human children
slaying the night's king is one thing
but an innocent offspring that seems
like a line that a stark wouldn't cross
and supposing further that brand spared
this child's life and then raised them
as a stark it could mean that the
night's Kings coupling with in other
introduced the blood of the others into
the stark line from very early on in the
family's history if that theory is true
the family's affinity for the cold feels
pretty natural as Catelyn Stark put it
in the books
the Starks were made for the cold
the seventh season finale the dragon and
the wolf ends on an ominous note as the
White Walkers break through the wall and
march into Westeros during the scene the
camera shows a bird's-eye view of the
army of the Dead marching forward what's
interesting about this shot is that the
White Walkers march in a formation that
appears highly reminiscent of the Starks
house sigil the image is flipped but the
resemblance is uncanny
there's clearly some sort of connection
between the stark house and the White
Walkers and by extension the knight King
a common theme in A Song of Ice and Fire
is the burden placed on characters by
their ancestors
Tyrion tries to prove his worth to his
father but ultimately has to come to
terms with his disapproval Jon Snow
grows up thinking he's illegitimate
denied the knowledge that he's heir to
the Iron Throne and Daenerys lives in
the shadow of her father the Mad King
Aerys ii and his terrible actions which
led to the near destruction of the
Targaryen house I'm not my father
no your eyes thank the gods if the
thirteenth Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch was a stark who fell in love with
one of the others it's not a stretch to
imagine that the other members of the
family could have crossed over to their
side as well we know from the show that
the night king used to be a man and
considering the history it makes the
most sense that the night king was a
stark if it's true it'll be a real cold
reckoning for the surviving members of
House Stark it would be especially
stressful for Jon Snow it's one thing to
find out he's related to his girlfriend
but his mortal enemy - it's almost too
much to keep track of that's why I read
so much Jon Snow check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]